[Music]
I'm sitting here with two of the stars
of neighbors - Seth Rogen Zac Efron hey
guys we are in this is the frat house it
is that they used to shoot the movie
both movies yes both movies this is
where long winter is this lovely
neighborhood in Los Angeles well this is
fun we're gonna play our an incredible
frat game this is a game is very popular
in fraternities Mario Kart this is Mario
Kart version eight is that right I don't
know we were thinking we should have
like stakes to it like stakes to the
game like if they lose like something
happens if you lose like a college thing
like people draw [ __ ] on each other's
faces like dicks okay hold on so if I
lost you would draw a dick on my face
okay are you guys proficient at drawing
I might have to trace axe that means axe
penis would be up against my face for
the third time this week
I brought a keg here great
I am wheat free right now so it's just a
green tea kombucha and then I wanted to
toke up like you badasses I know this
guy's high pretty much 24/7
I brought a vape pen so omega oils in it
this is lowering my cholesterol with all
right we've established my street cred I
can hang with anyone at this point
despite the fact that I'm actually old
enough to have voted for Eisenhower
whoa that's impossible you didn't put us
in the game what does that have a I
think I'm blue I'm blue and then you go
since you was gonna girl no but what's
the dip thing where am i I don't even
know where I am
dude this is awesome are we supposed to
get so bad at this before you draw any
genitalia this is television and we have
to follow a certain code now this is
hand drawing this real safe practices
yes absolutely real
so gentlemen these are all acceptable
ZAR okay these are accept so it seems
like the urethra is what makes it a
penis what are you doing us right now so
you use this freckle as the urethra
something like that yeah well now we
know it look at my own natural arm hair
has created hair look at two doors to
this
this is the most animated I don't beat
you guys wait my butt you guys waiting
for me oh this is awkward
I think that was pretty good for like a
good profile you know I went to college
didn't okay that's great
oh you should garlic a teardrop dick
like he killed the dick in prison
you know what's nice I'm going straight
from this to lunch with my in-laws
[Music]
that's good well it's a droopy burger
okay guys we just got some disconcerting
news this is from our standards
department at Turner yeah
the outline of a penis can be shown but
should not be overly graphic or detailed
we cannot show depictions of the penis
urinating or ejaculated that maybe that
could be our where where they got us
what if they're music notes Zach may
have cracked this he is now going to
convert what could be confused for
ejaculate thank you for the American
turn into musical notes so that now
these are penises that are singing
that's a G minor you should be able to
draw the penis you want to draw in
America that's we're all about that's
why I voted for Donald Trump yeah come
on I think someone's getting some new
artwork that's great oh you did
okay it's a heart
[Music]
not bad at all okay then the game is my
legs and it is ready to eat for everyone
the moviemakers 2 comes out May 20th
make sure you check that out
thank you very much thank you guys and
I'm pretty much out of show business
[Applause]
okay if you enjoyed this freak show and
you want more clueless gamers click
right here there's a lot of them I've
got a lot of free time right there's
where you click
[Laughter]